bajeux bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors cela
faisait un peu plus d'un an à que les
libanais attendait ce jour celui où un
nouveau gouvernement viendrait en place
on sait qu'aujourd'hui le parlement a
commencé sa séance pour accorder sa
confiance à ce nouveau cabinet est ce
qu'on peut parler d'une simple formalité
où peut-on s'attendre à un compte est un
coup de théâtre
bonjour
commençons par dire que la plupart des
libanais vivant
la formation de ce gouvernement en
particulier comme une défaite une
défaite pour soi-disant la révolte la
révolution
qui dure depuis maintenant presque deux
ans
c'est une défaite parce que c'est en fin
de compte on le voit comme le
gouvernement du hezbollah avec
avec couverture
du premier ministre qui est avant pied
sunnites et du président saleh qui est
qui est chrétien mais qui sont tous en
fin de compte soul en lice totale du
congo lance
alors allez-y
en ce qui concerne le coup de théâtre je
ne pense pas je crois que le président
nagib mikati
sera
et ça a été décidé bien avant qu'ils ne
soient dorés on sait que le prédécesseur
de la gym mais quand tu es saadi j'avais
renoncé à former un gouvernement au bout
de neuf mois qu'est ce qui peut faire la
différence aujourd'hui on
on sent que voilà vous n'êtes pas
optimiste concernant ce gouvernement
mais il ya quand même de bons éléments
qui pourraient justement essayer de
mettre en place des réformes pour pour
faire avancer le liban non maintenant
parce que ceux qui ont détruit le liban
ne peuvent pas leurs efforts mais les
gens qui ont causé les partis politiques
qui ont causé la destruction totale de
l'économie du liban et de son tissu de
son tissu social et qui ont poussé des
centaines de milliers de gens à quitter
le pays
en deux mois ne pourront pas on n'a pas
conscience qu'ils pourront enfin de
comment faire des réformes ça c'est de
1,2 la différence entre premier ministre
c'est celui-là c'est que les américains
n'avaient pas donné le feu vert si vous
voulez
du temps de ben ali et qui l'ont fait
pour je ne sais pas quel prix le présent
à cran
il a consulté avec les iraniens les
iraniens ont donné leur accord ils nous
ont vendus je pense que encore une fois
les les
l'international a vendu le liban
malheureusement cette fois ci pour le
prendre de niro
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui concrètement
les attentes du peuple libanais
je crois que malheureusement sommes un
peuple qui a été soumis par la force des
choses
notre notre plus grande victoire de la
journée c'est de pouvoir faire le plein
d'essence ou bien avoir quelques heures
d'électricité par jour où trouver un
médicament dont on a besoin nous sommes
réduits à 100 malheureusement
la taz analyste politique et spécialiste
du moyen-orient merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions ce matin